[Music]
there's so much that we've been talking
about over the last uh several hours not
only last evening but also this
morning one of the things we need to
look at is that we need to understand
that our church is in
crisis and if that hasn't become evident
to you yet it will
in this next
presentation we've been wrestling not
against flesh and blood but we've been
wrestling against principalities against
Powers against spiritual wickedness in
high
places and the only
solution to overcoming this most
desperate evil that is coming into our
church is putting on the armor of
God when we understand rightfully that
the armor of God this helmet of
salvation the breastplate of
righteousness The Shield of Faith the
sword of the spirit being G girded with
the loins of Truth and Sh our feet Shaw
with the gospel of peace we understand
that each one of those is a picture of
Christ
himself so it's not we who overcome but
rather it's Christ who overcomes in us
and through us and when we rightly
understand that then we will correctly
understand the power of the Everlasting
gospel before I enter into this message
this morning once again I'd like i' like
to invite you to join me in
prayer as we pray not only for the
baptism of the Holy Spirit but that our
ears would be opened and that our eyes
would be clear to see will you join
me our loving
father Lord again we come before you
seeking your guidance seeking your
wisdom father we ask that our minds
would be clear this morning and that our
ears would be swift to hear and our
eyes prepared with isav so they might be
Discerning Lord I ask now that as I
stand before your
people that it would not be my words
that come forth but rather your
words father you have impressed my mind
throughout the week and the time getting
ready for this particular presentation
but at the end of the day Lord I submit
myself completely to you as I come into
your presence Lord I ask that you would
fill me up so that I might overflow and
be a blessing to your children in Jesus
name
amen as we get a little bit older we
find that things aren't always as easy
to read so we have to use the cheaters
every now and then but but I invite with
I invite you right now to turn in your
Bibles to the book of
Titus we're going to go to the book of
Titus Chapter
2 specifically we'll look at verses 11-1
15 as we read through
this please understand that I consider
this to be one of the most powerful
passages in the
scripture yet I think often times
because of a casual reading of the text
we fail to really understand what is
being said here by the Apostle
Paul you know I'm indebted to the late
Elder Joe Cruz for bringing this to my
attention over 30 years ago he gave a
message called The Power of a positive
no and he used this text as the basis
for that presentation and as I heard
that message so long ago it it resonated
with me and it's continued to stick with
me over the time and not long ago
probably about six seven months ago I
listened to that message once again and
I was
impressed that this is the text that we
need to
consider when we understand and look
into the power of the Everlasting gospel
the word of the Lord says for the grace
of God that bringeth salvation hath
appeared to all men teaching us that
denying ungodliness and worldly lusts we
should live soberly righteously and
godly in this present
world looking for that blessed hope and
the Glorious appearing of the great God
and our Savior Jesus Christ who gave
himself for us that he might redeem us
from all iniquity and purify unto
himself a peculiar people zealous of
good works these things speak and exhort
and rebuke with all authority let no man
despise thee
as we've been
looking at these various issues of the
emerging church and and how they're
affecting uh what we believe things are
being
Twisted Ephesians 5:11 is our watch word
in terms that we are to expose the error
we are to have no fellowship with
Darkness but all we do if all we do is
focus on the
error and and we don't counter that with
a modom of
truth then we've missed the entire Point
what I have found in my three years with
the ministry ever since coming out of
the US Air Force back in 2012 is I found
that we are very good as a
people of getting our doctorates in
error what do I mean by that we like to
study all these things that are wrong we
like to know what's going on for example
we like to know that the spiritual
formation movement is a problem we like
to see that the pope is really busy
right now and what all that entails but
what we have done is we have not been
getting our doctrate in truth but rather
we're stopping at elementary
school and there's a much broader
concept here we don't use the sword as a
defensive
weapon the sword is an offensive weapon
but it has to be wielded
properly it has to be wielded with
proficiency and the only way that we
become proficient in wielding the sword
is understanding what the truth is not
knowing what the error
is how do we destroy error do we destroy
it by using error against error but
rather do we take
truth and fight the error with the truth
the Lord said it is
written and he continually used the
scripture and the truth
therein to combat the error that was
even plaguing Israel at that particular
time we are to do the
same today's
message is specifically for us for the
time in which we're living which I
believe as I look out into the world and
I pay attention to the headlines now and
again I believe that we are the final
generation
brothers and sisters we need to
understand why we are
here we need to understand why we are
seventh day Adventists why we embrace
the things that we do we need to have a
good firm grasp because our faith is
going to be put to the
test and we cannot fall back and say
well because Pastor so and so said this
or evangelist so and so said that no we
have to have the spirit working within
us we have to understand the truth not
only do we have to understand the truth
we have to become the truth and reflect
the glory of Christ it has to transform
us completely we must have a total
transformation if we don't know what is
required of us as seventh day
Adventists very succinctly sister white
says we will be unfit for the
kingdom we will not pass the test
that will come so we have to understand
what that test is and how to combat that
test and there are many distractions out
there trying to get us off of the
pathway of
Truth we need to know what those
distractions are but we don't want to go
off on rabbit trails at the exclusion of
the truth we have to be very
careful the messages that you've heard
already and the ones that you're going
to hear this afternoon they are designed
to
ensure that you are informed and that
you are not going to be deceived by the
enemy's
camp and I need to stress this important
issue this is not about people this is
not about personalities this is about
the
enemy the enemy of souls at the end of
the day he is the accuser of the
Brethren and we need to understand that
often times people are misguided
misinformed deceived and as a result
they either wittingly and sometimes even
unwittingly bind
themselves to the enemy's
Camp Pastor Howard this morning
mentioned that I had shared a testimony
yesterday as we were getting
together about the impact that his book
had on me and my
studies as I was going through my
doctoral studies several years
ago I had a professor who was
raised as a Dutch reformed believer in
South
Africa um somebody who I would consider
to be very sincere very knowledgeable
and desirous of
Truth when he learned about my
faith he readily told me that our church
is in
crisis but his definition of a crisis
and my definition of a crisis were
diametrically opposed to one
another and as I I began to learn some
things through the assignments that we
were given the readings that we were had
uh were told to read I began to get
seriously
concerned these were part of the things
that we had to just skim over and
understand how all the facets of
Christianity were coming
together and God saved me and he saved
me from going down the wrong path two
ways number one I realized that as I was
going down this pathway in my doctoral
studies uh to be uh focusing on the
ecclesial side of organizational
leadership that more than ever before I
needed to get into the spirit of
Prophecy you see if you're driving from
California to the east coast you're
going to use a road atlas and that road
atlas will likely take you from I80 or I
10 or I40 or whatever to get from
California all the way out to the east
Coast but let's say for example I'm
going to Washington DC that road atlas
becomes ineffective once I get to
Washington DC I need a city
map and so the Bible is my road
atlas it takes me exactly where I need
to be but the spirit of Prophecy is my
city
map if I want to get to the Washington
mall and know where the Smithsonian is
and especially for me the aviation
Enthusiast that I am that's where I want
to go I use L the city map I need
Fidelity and the spirit of Prophecy
gives us Fidelity so I knew first and
foremost that was very important if I
was going to move forward in these
studies
second I had purchased a book just maybe
a week or two prior called the Omega
Rebellion by Elder Howard as I read
through that book
voraciously I began to see that some of
the things that were being espoused by
my professor were in correct not only
were they incorrect they were
heretical within Christianity at large
notwithstanding the fact that I'm a
Seventh Day
Adventist just overarching in
Christianity and so thus began a
relationship of going head-to-head for
the next two years with this
professor it wasn't easy but the Lord
sustained me and I will tell you that
unless we are paying attention very
closely we are not smart enough to
discern truth from error in and of
ourselves we have been given the
scriptures we have been given the spirit
of Prophecy and we have been given works
by Faithful Servants of the Lord like
Elder Howard and we are to use these to
our
advantage because they will keep us from
deception they will
I think it's only fair to tell you that
not only the messages that you've heard
but the ones that you will hear this
afternoon they're only the tip of the
iceberg that threatens to sink our
ship you cannot leave here and just say
I have everything I need to know you
will have to study deeper especially
when it comes to the concepts of Truth
and understanding the message of the
Everlasting gospel that is what we are
about as seventh day Adventists is the
Everlasting gospel
we've been raised up as a movement of
Bible believing Christians whose mission
it is to proclaim the finishing work of
the final atonement of Jesus Christ as
our high priest in the most holy place
of the Heavenly
Sanctuary that is a unique teaching to
seventh day adventism you see there are
others who teach the Sabbath it's not
unique to us there are others who teach
the state of the Dead there are others
who understand
Hellfire there are under others who
understand the health message there are
others who understand tithing there are
even others who understand the
sanctuary but they understand it in
terms of
furniture they do not understand it in
terms of the sanctuary
cleansed that is unique to seventh day
adventism and this is why we have been
raised up as the Capstone of the
Protestant Reformation to do a finishing
work that Luther began actually you can
add go further back to John Wickliffe
the morning star of the Reformation but
of course it was Luther with the
Gutenberg Press to his advantage that
got his 95 thesis out and thus began the
configration that
ensued the
purpose of the Everlasting
gospel is to vindicate God's character
before the UN universe and to stop the
mouth of the
accuser the power of the Everlasting
gospel is that by a total surrender to
Christ through a complete consecration
we can be transformed into his likeness
that is God manifest In the Flesh such
that we partake of the divine nature and
have the mind of
Christ and he is our
example who did no sin nor was guile
found in his
mouth so what is our message our message
is that through a complete consecrated
relationship that Earth's final
generation can have sinless Perfection
of
character the character of Christ not a
popular
message but it is truth and we're going
to go through that and look at at that a
little more
carefully now with what we've heard
already in the Symposium I need to take
pause and state that the desired end of
the emerging Church movement according
to the biblical Research Institute is
the complete deconstruction of the
church the complete deconstruction of
the church moreover a deconstruction of
the Protestant Reformation now there was
only one group raised up in 15 34 whose
aim it was to destroy the Protestant
Reformation and that was the Society of
Jesus under Ignatius of Lola in
1534 their sole aim then and nearly 500
years later is to destroy the Protestant
Reformation now two minutes ago I
mentioned that seventh day adventism is
the
Capstone of the Protestant Reformation
we have been raised up to finish the
work we as a people are to get settled
in the truth so that we might be safe to
save and that is a very solemn thought
when we consider the fact that many of
us think that we are okay but maybe
we're really not and those are some of
the things I want to explore this
morning how is the church going to be
deconstructed and what kind of
deconstruction are we talking about I
think we'll see these things much more
clearly as we delve into the scripture a
little more and we look into the spirit
of Prophecy now I personally have often
wondered when I read about the Omega of
apostasy okay Omega means the end so
therefore the alpha is the beginning how
does all this relate when sister white
says that as I saw this I trembled for
our
people she had a lot to say about this
back in 1903 and 1904 during the time of
j John Harvey Kellogg specifically when
his misguided views of the godhead his
misunderstanding of the medical
missionary work and its prominence and
overshadowing of the evangelism portion
of our work began to take people the
wrong
way he was having the wrong
Focus he had the right ideas in many
respects in terms of medical missionary
work it needed to be done it is the
final work that we are to be doing as a
people but not at the
exclusion of
evangelism but also edifying the
brothers and the
sisters that must be
done sister White had a few things to
say about that in selected messages
volume one she writes the following the
word of the Lord has come to me that
there is a decided work to be done in
warning our medical missionaries against
the dangers and perils that surround
them specifically talking about this
Alpha of heresy that had come into the
church she writes No Lie is of the truth
if we follow cunningly devised fables we
Unite with the enemy's forces against
God and Christ God calls upon those who
have been wearing a yoke of human
manufacturer to break this yoke and no
longer be the bond Servants of
men so what is she saying there in a nut
sh too many people are looking at John
Harvey Kellogg and not keeping their
eyes fixed on Christ We cannot put our
trust in the flesh We cannot put our
trust in
men even everything that I am saying to
you this morning I want you to go back
and be good bans and check it
out don't trust that I have everything
correct I pray to the Lord that I do
I've asked that the words that I speak
are indeed
his
moreover if you have a question about
something or say something or hear
something that I said that might be a
little bit inaccurate or might be off I
want you to bring it to my
attention that's the way we work right
we have to do that because as we begin
to give these messages we have to uplift
one another we have to ensure AR iron
sharpening iron so that we are prepared
for the final counter offensive that's
going to take place Kellogg's views set
the stage for a series ious diversion of
our message that would see its fruition
in the late 1950s and also through the
80s through the false teachings of Heen
stall of FR of Anderson of brimsmead and
of Ford and even
today through the misguided work of the
one project and many other church
leaders this has all but seen a complete
eradication of the sublime truth
explicit not only in the scriptures but
in the spirit of Prophecy and it's all
gone almost all gone in the practice of
God's final
generation so we have a work to do and
the work to do is number one to
understand the work but number two how
to finish that
work that is the most important thing
that we can understand here today
brothers and sisters what is the power
of the Everlasting gospel sister White
had some more to say about the alpha now
I want you to pay very close attention
to what she's saying here about the
alpha of apostasy
put your as my mom used to say put your
thinking cap on and pay very close
attention she says the battle is on this
is in first selected messages page
194 Satan and his angels are working
with all deceivableness and
unrighteousness they are untiring in
their efforts to draw Souls away from
the truth away from righteousness to
spread ruin throughout the
Universe they work with marvelous
industry to furnish a multitude of
deceptions to take Souls
captive so what's the purpose of the
deceptions and the alpha and not only
now the Omega of heresies it's to take
Souls
captive the devil does not want you to
get settled in the
truth he does not want us to be safe to
save rather he wants to help us and make
us think that we are on the right path
and often times we are parallel to the
right path but we are not on the right
path you see I used to fly for a living
when I was in the US Air
Force and one of the things that we used
to do is fly what was called an
instrument Landing system approach
they're much more upscale these days as
they use GPS but using the old radio
navigation AIDS it was very interesting
about 18 miles out you would get what
was called the localizer frequency it
would give you course guidance and as
that far out you have a wide birth but
the whole point of the course is to
bring you to the runway and it becomes
more and more narrow as you get to The
Landing Zone to the point where at the
end you have zero room for
error now if you equate this with sister
White's first vision of the narrow way
the path became more and more narrow
such that at the end they were taking
off their shoes and their socks the only
thing that they could rely on was
keeping their eyes fixed on Christ
now this particular approach if properly
followed will take you keep you right on
course and you know there are winds on
final at times that try to keep you a
drift and you can fly parallel to the
course but I will guarantee you that if
you do not fly on course when it comes
to the runway you will not land you will
have to go
around well if you don't have enough
fuel to go around then there's only one
option at that particular point
moreover there is a what's called a
Glide
slope such that after you get to a
certain point the airplane is fully
configured to land everything's set you
follow this Glide path down and the most
important thing to do is to have known
pitch settings and known power settings
so that you're not busy moving the Yoke
and moving the power in other words you
have to be proficient in the truth of
flying the
airplane some sometimes it becomes too
treacherous and you have to put on the
autopilot but no matter what you have to
trust your instruments and you know what
our instruments are our instruments are
this and the spirit of Prophecy they
will bring us to a safe landing each and
every
time that is so important for us to
understand now continuing with this
passage their efforts are
unceasing the enemy is ever seeking to
lead Souls into infidelity and
skepticism he would do away with God and
with Christ now here's the Crux of this
passage who was made
flesh and dwelt among us to teach that
in obedience to God's will we may be
victorious over
sin so what did she call the alpha of
heresies she said that the nature of
Christ was coming into
question and that the very teaching from
our beginning as a people that we could
have victory over sin through Christ's
Ministry in the most holy place was now
being taken out of the way she said that
new books would be written books of a
new order even to the point where books
would be written saying that there is no
Sanctuary do we have books like that
today I believe that was shared last
night so slowly by slowly piece by piece
we see this
deconstruction of who we are as a people
of who we are as seventh day
Adventists we are not just Adventists
there are other Adventists out there but
we are seventh day Adventists why is
that not only do we look forward to the
second coming of Christ but we
understand that God finished his work on
the seventh
day God gave us this name because we are
to finish the work of the final
atonement
that is our calling that is why we have
been raised up using the subtle
deceptions of spiritualism the devil
would attempt to eradicate the idea that
Jesus nature was the same as our fallen
nature and that God's people can be
victorious over appetite and the inward
passions and desires of the flesh just
as he was by surrendering his will
completely to the
father nothing that Christ did was of
his own accord nothing that he did was
outside of being totally surrendered to
the
father he was our
example nothing he did was on his own
nothing we do can be of our own
everything has to be completely
surrendered to
Christ said another way Satan would do
all he can to remove any thought that
Earth's final generation might have
victory over sin through a total
surrender to Christ that we might
reflect his character and do the
necessary work works as discussed in
Isaiah
58 this is what we understand as
righteousness by
faith not my faith his faith amen habach
2:4 it says the just shall live by his
faith whose faith my faith my faith is
but filthy rags because then it becomes
works for by grace are you saved through
faith and that not of yourselves the
faith is not of yourself is the gift of
of
God not of Works lest any man should
boast it is the faith of
Jesus looking back at the passage we
read in Titus I want to make a take a
moment to clear up any confusion that
might Exist by those who sometimes read
into the text or think that it doesn't
actually say what it says I've recently
heard that there is no such thing as a
plain reading of the scripture
um to that end I I have to counter that
and say well if that's the case then
we're in
trouble because the scripture is to be
read plainly to be understood clearly we
don't need to be going through a bunch
of mental gymnastics and
etical uh exercises to make it say
something that it doesn't really
say there can be no question about what
Paul is saying in Titus 2: 11-15 the m
Masterpiece statement is probably the
most complete
description of God's ideal for his
people to be found in the entire Bible
Paul somehow manages to touch on all if
of the great Christian lifestyle
doctrines which should characterize the
true church today it runs contrary to
what the emerging Church movement
Embraces let's take a
look Paul says that we are to be
redeemed from all iniquity
what is the definition of the word
all it means
all okay am I to read something into
that I don't think so so all iniquity in
other words all
lawlessness we have been shapen in
iniquity and outside of a walking in the
spirit we are
condemned but we are to be redeemed from
lawlessness it says that the Lord wants
to purify unto himself a peculiar people
he wants to do what he wants to purify
them now when you make something pure
you make it completely clean not like
what was it Ivory soap 99 and 44 100s
per. because 9940 99 and 44 100% truth
equals 100%
error you get that that's not new math
that's God math
any smidgen of error mixed with the
truth makes everything
false and we are not smart enough in and
of ourselves to discern what is truth
and what is error outside of the leading
of the
spirit we have been admonished time and
time again walk in the spirit and you
will not fulfill the lust of the
flesh that's the only way we can have
that discernment we are to be zealous of
good works is what Paul says denying
ungodliness and worldly lusts again only
through the spirit and looking for that
blessed hope we should be looking for
the second coming of
Christ but before the second of coming
of Christ there is a work that has to be
done a work of preparation for God's
final generation there is a testing
truth that is looming on the
horizon and we have to be prepared for
it not when the truth or the test comes
but rather before it
comes in these words we find the
doctrine of true
sanctification and a total victory over
all iniquity in other words the carnal
mind and flesh can be overcome by
following the very simple words of John
the Baptist he must
increase but I must
decrease and oh by the way the order of
operation is all
important you see we cannot divest
ourselves of
self we can't do it we must be dead to
self but we can't do it but why not
because the flesh does not want to
die the old man wants to get a a firm
grip on who we
are and you know what a lot of seventh
day Adventists these days are practicing
necromancy and don't even realize it
we are told that the old man has been
crucified if we are in Christ why do we
try to talk to the dead
then why is it that we revisit all this
why do we allow the devil to take us
back to the old man and we have this
conversation with him and we don't get
the victory but rather we get caught up
in this repetitive
cycle we have to keep our eyes focused
on Christ he must increase in other
words we have to let the spirit fill us
up so that the selfish desires of our
carnal nature are flushed
out it's only through that displacement
that we will have total Victory you see
there is a mathematical principle that
two objects cannot occupy the same space
simultaneously you are either all the
Devils or all the Lords there's no in
between going for a lukewarm state which
is the the third
option means that you go for the cold
State and not the hot
State like Peter Paul boldly declared
the possibility of being without spot
and blameless but he also identified the
overcoming group as standing in
particular contrast to others around
them they have a Zeal for good
works and this obedience marks them as
God's final generation you see we have a
lot in our heads as seventh day
Adventists we've been given the truth so
we think a lot and we say a lot but one
of the things that we haven't done a
good job of is the manifestation of
those good
works it must go head to heart to
hand it is called the Perfection of our
faith that James speaks of in James
2:22 faith is made perfect in love and
love is set forth by the fruit of the
spirit which is good
works so if you see somebody hungry
spiritually or physically feed them if
you see somebody thirsty spiritually or
physically give them to drink if you see
somebody naked either spiritually or
physically clothe
them give them what they
need this is what the Lord would have us
to
do for by grace
are we
saved furthermore Paul wrote The Grace
which brings salvation would teach the
faithful Saints to look for the Blessed
hope of Christ's coming they would be
living in joyful
expectancy of his soon Advent and this
end time Church would separate from the
indulgent lifestyle of the carnal
majority and deny ungodliness and
worldly lusts the final Church God's
final people will be wise
virgins they will have their vessels
filled with oil now often times we look
at that oil and we say that is the
filling of the Holy Spirit it is but
what does the Holy Spirit do it refines
our
characters and character is not
transferable character is formed through
a oneon-one relationship with Jesus
Christ through the walking of the
spirit we must repent we must confess we
must be consecrated but those three
cannot come until we understand that we
have a need for Christ and we'll never
understand that we have a need for
Christ until we first understand God's
love for
us and those are the first five chapters
of steps to
Christ if you haven't read it read it
again for the first
time it will change your life it truly
will however there are those in the
emerging Church movement who would try
to convince us that the idea of
overcoming sin in the FLH is foreign to
the true gospel they would like to tell
us adventism moved away from that
position in 1957 with questions on
Doctrine and then further in 1979 and
1980 with Ford's new Theology and those
who believe in the teachings of Ellen
White or ml Andreas or herb Douglas on
the subject of character Perfection have
departed from true Christianity that is
what they would like to tell
us that we're missing the point
that we are focusing too much on the
works of the
law and they like to use sister White's
writings when she said that the law the
law the law has been preached until it's
been as dry as the hills of
gilboa but the problem is every time
there is it's Newtonian physics what's
going on here folks for every action
there's an equal and opposite reaction
and that's really what's going on with
the emerging Church
movement if I had a one in my pocket I
would show you but let me ask you a
question how many sides to a
coin okay I see two no there's
three you've got an obverse you have a
reverse and then you have the
edge and that narrow way is where we are
to be you see it's real easy to fall
into one camp or the other and get
caught up in this diet tribe that goes
on between well he said she said they
said they said whatever
we have to be grounded in the truth
walking the straight and narrow
way and what you'll often times find is
when you're on the straight and narrow
way you'll get attacked by both
sides trust me it
happens the belief that we will never
have character Perfection until Jesus
returns is foreign to the
gospel Jesus rightly said be therefore
perfect even as your father which is in
heaven is perfect Matthew 5 48 and until
that time they tell us we will continue
to sin over and over and over again
getting caught up in this do fail do
fail and there's no
Victory now folks I came out of Roman
Catholicism over 20 years ago I
understand what that's like never having
Victory only defeat after defeat after
defeat
and so after a while you just back up
and saywell okay maybe it is only by
grace that I'm saved I am not going to
get victory over sin it is all about
forgiveness there's nothing about
character Perfection that's part of the
Gospel so you can see where people might
fall into this
trap and it's up to you brothers and
sisters to understand the truth to bring
them out of that trap and we don't bring
them out of the Trap by saying come out
of the Trap we go up to the Trap and we
hand that give them a hand and we pull
them
out that's the important part we extend
the hand to bring them
out we simply cannot just say come out
it's more to
that now there's this
issue that the emerging Church espouses
in particular the one project of Jesus
all now I don't have a problem with that
statement in that Jesus is all
so fundamentally I'm okay with it but
then I ask the question at the exclusion
of
what because the desire is about laying
aside our
differences in terms of standards in
terms of Doctrine and just focus on
Jesus and Jesus all and the true church
WIll emerge don't worry about lifestyle
don't worry about what you wear don't
worry about what you eat don't worry
about what you drink think don't worry
about what you watch or listen to but
rather just focus on
Jesus and the true church WIll
emerge they would rather have an
experience to have the correct theology
as to having the correct theology to
have a correct
experience the very
teachings upon which our movement was
founded are being uprooted by those who
would see true seventh day adventism
historic seventh day adventism wither
away and many many are falling into the
deception some of you may even know
them so therefore we need to uplift
Christ and the truth his word teaches
regarding the power of the Everlasting
gospel and the power of the Everlasting
gospel is framed in the re in Revelation
14: 6-2 The Three Angels
messages and and so as we look at the
first Angel's message we're going to
understand what that power
is and what this gospel is when Jesus
said and this Gospel of the Kingdom
shall be preached in all the world for a
witness unto all nations then shall the
End come we're going to understand what
that witness
is we're familiar with the term
Everlasting
gospel but we don't always I think
understand the power that it gives and
what we need to do to embrace that power
but we can know that in John 1:12 John
wrote as many as received him that is
Christ to them gave he power to become
the sons of God even to them that
believe on his name now what does it
mean to be a son or a daughter of God it
means to be made or remade into the
express image of
Christ so the power comes from the
Everlasting gospel it's not just about
forgiveness
it's about Recreation a complete and
total
restoration how do we embrace
it the just shall live by his faith the
Faith of Christ many today talk about
the Three Angels messages yet because of
the confusion that's ensued since the
1950s many Miss what the Lord is really
trying to tell us we have been caught in
the trap of teaching the right day to go
to church for example but we have missed
the substance of what it means to be
Sabbath
Keepers we have missed the substance of
what it means to be God's final
generation so let's open up our Bibles
and take a look at the first Angel's
message Revelation 14 6 and 7
specifically and I saw another Mighty
angel fly in the midst of Heaven having
the Everlasting gospel to preach to them
that dwell on the earth and to every
nation and Kindred and tongue and people
now I'll stop right there notice that
it's to every nation and Kindred and
tongue and people it doesn't say just
for those in North America this thus
just for those in Europe or in South
America or in Asia this is for the
entire
world and what this particular passage
implies is that we need to let go of
what we think we
know we need to get into God's
culture and submit to him completely how
am I supposed to take my North American
paradigms go to China and project them
on them when they don't think that
way but if I subject everything about
myself to the
scripture such that I'm transformed this
metaph morphosis takes place such that I
become a new creature in
Christ and have the culture of
Heaven do you think then people might
listen because it's no longer I who
speak but Christ who is speaking through
me so this is what we need to understand
about the Everlasting gospel in
particular how it goes to the world
saying with a loud voice fear God and
give glory to him for the hour of his
judgment has come and worship him that
made Heaven and Earth and the Sea and
The Fountains of waters four parts to
the first Angel's message fear God the
first part give glory to him for the
hour of his judgment is come and then
worship him that made so we're going to
briefly examine these four parts and
help us get a better understanding of
what it's trying to tell us in terms of
our role and our finishing work as
seventh day
Adventists Psalms 3411 tells us Come Ye
children hearken unto me and I will
teach you the fear of the Lord so we are
to listen
to what the Lord has to say through his
word through the revelation of the
prophets to include the spirit of
Prophecy we will then understand the
fear of the Lord the fear of the Lord is
clean Psalms 199 tells us enduring
forever the judgments of the Lord are
true and righteous
altogether Psalms 111:10 says the fear
of the Lord is the beginning of wisdom a
good understanding have all they that do
his Commandments his praise in endureth
forever Proverbs 1:7 tells us the fear
of the Lord is the beginning of
knowledge but fools despise wisdom and
instruction Proverbs 88:13 goes on to
tell us the fear of the Lord is to hate
evil pride and arrogancy and the evil
way and the frow word mouth do I hate
you know so often we talk about the
concept of
sin and yes it's true we need to have
victory over the drinking and the the
smoking and the overeating and the
fornication and the pornography and
whatever else that we see from an
external part but what the Lord wants to
deal with is
this he wants to deal with the heart he
wants to get to the very root of the sin
problem which is
selfishness the opposite of love is not
hate brothers and sisters it is
selfishness because God's love is
charitable it is without thought of self
when we think of the word charity more
often than not we think I'm giving
something but not expecting anything in
return that's God's
love and until we realize that the Lord
wants to cleanse the heart we will not
have victory over sin
amen Proverbs 14:26 and7 says in the
fear of the Lord is strong confidence
you think he can do it we know he can do
it and his children shall have a place
place of Refuge when you think of Refuge
you think of a
sanctuary you think of a place where you
can have a resit and rest in god notice
I said the word rest what does that
imply it implies the finishing work of
the
Sabbath to bring us back into God's
favor the fear of the Lord is a Fountain
of Life to depart from the snares of
death proverbs 1923 says the fear of the
Lord tends to life and he that has it
shall abide satisfied he shall not be
visited with evil do you see the Lord
can give us power over
Temptation the very Temptation that
comes into our minds immediately we run
to the Refuge because in him is strong
confidence and he then pushes it away
who gets the victory Christ gets the
Victory and how do we do that John 15:5
Jesus said I am the vine ye are the
branches he that abides in me and I in
him the same bringeth forth what much
fruit for without me you can do
nothing we need to run to
Jesus we need to let him Embrace us and
you know we run to him he Embraces us
yes he clothes us with his robe of
righteousness but you know what he does
when we're all dirty
underneath he takes the robe off and he
cleans us up
he makes sure that what's underneath is
worthy of what's going on on the
surface so if our external lives look
good he wants to ensure that our
internal lives are
good we've got to get to the root of the
matter Isaiah 2:10 tells us enter into
the Rock who's our Rock Christ
and hide thee into the Dust for the fear
of the Lord and for the glory of his
majesty not our Majesty but his majesty
so
to understand the fear of the Lord means
to have an intimate relationship with
him through
Christ Thou shalt love the Lord thy God
with all thine heart all thy soul with
all thy
might that is what we you're being told
into fearing God let us hear the
conclusion of the
matter fear God and keep his
Commandments for this is the whole duty
of man we must enter into a saving
relationship with
him what does it mean to give glory to
him simply put we remember the story in
Exodus 33 when Moses is on the mountain
and he says Lord show me your what Your
Glory and the Lord says and it shall
come to pass while my glory passes by
that I will put you in the Cliff of The
Rock and will cover you with my hand
while I pass by and he did that and then
the Lord and then Moses looked upon the
Lord in Exodus 346 and7 we see and the
Lord passed by before him and proclaimed
the Lord
Yahweh ywe Adonai the Lord God Elohim
we are getting a picture of the Eternal
one the all ever existing one we're
getting a picture of Jesus
Christ as revealed to Moses merciful and
gracious longsuffering and abundant in
goodness and Truth keeping Mercy for
thousands forgiving iniquity and
transgression and sin three different
types of ways of offending God through
iniquity law lessness transgression
outright rebellion and then sinful
actions to include
thoughts and that will by no means clear
the guilty visiting the iniquity of the
fathers upon the children upon the
children's children unto the third and
the fourth
generation numbers 14:21 says but as
truly as I live all the Earth shall be
filled with the glory of the Lord
Deuteronomy 5:24 goes on to say behold
the Lord Our God has showed us his glory
and his great
and we have heard his voice out of the
midst of the fire and we have seen this
day that God doth talk with man and he
liveth God will talk with us and we will
live we will see his glory out of the
midst of the fire what fires the fires
of tribulation the fires of trials that
we go through they are refining fires to
take the gold and move it through the
fiery Kiln so the dross will be taken
out of the way I counsel thee to buy
what gold tried in the
fire you see what the Lord is wanting us
to
do Isaiah 40:5 it says and the glory of
the Lord shall be revealed and All Flesh
shall see it together for the mouth of
the Lord has spoken it the world will
see it in his
people the revelation of Jesus Christ
comes not only through the written word
but through the Living Word of his
people and we have been called to be
that final
generation habach 2114 says for the
Earth shall be filled with the knowledge
of the glory of the Lord as the waters
cover the
sea and then Jesus so rightly says you
are the light of the world a city that
is set on a hill cannot be hidden
neither do men light a candle and put it
under a bushel no they put it up on a
lampstand so that it might give light to
all who are in the
home and then he says the conclusion let
your light so shine before
men that they may see your good works
and glorify your father which is in
heaven it is the works the righteous
Deeds of the saints that the world will
look upon and they will look not at the
pale reflection but they will look at
the source of the
light and and give glory to God our
father but we have a
problem we have a serious problem
because Romans 3:23 says for all have
sinned and come short of the glory of
God but yet we are called to give glory
to
him right the angel is very
explicit give glory to
him so God has to do something with the
sin problem he has to correct the sin
problem if we are to give glory to him
because it's the sin problem that's
keeping us from giving glory to him by
what we say by what we think by what we
do
and how can God then be
blessed how can we show a picture a true
revelation of Jesus Christ if we are
encumbered by
sin even though we might look good on
the outside we become White washed
seers but inside we are but dead men's
bones and that is the purpose not only
of the sanctuary but the sanctuary
cleansed it is to perfectly reflect the
glory of Christ Christ in you the hope
of
glory that is the
teaching now we are told that the hour
of his judgment has
come and we know that in 1 Peter 4 17
that judgment must first begin at the
house of
God Ecclesiastes 12:14 says every that
God will bring every work into judgment
every secret thing whether it's good or
whether it's
evil now what part of every are we
failing to understand
here every means what means every let's
just keep it simple folks means
everything all right let's not get too
complex here so everything we think
everything we do is passing before the
Judgment so what's
happening this idea of the hour of his
judgment is come do you know that it has
a parallel passage that is
synonymous it's called unto 2,300 days
then shall the sanctuary be
cleansed so what is the purpose of the
investigative
judgment the cleansing of the
sanctuary the cleansing of God's people
preparing for the final
generation and cleansing means
purification and purification means
Holiness and Holiness means without
sin that is the purpose of the sanctuary
message that's the purpose of the
investigative judgment it is not Santa
Claus theology where somebody's making a
list and checking it twice to find out
who's naughty and who's nice we already
know who's naughty and there's only one
who is
nice so the purpose of the investigative
judgment is not to keep us living in
fear but rather it's to give us hope
it's to let us know that probation has
not yet
closed it's to help us to understand
that Christ wants us to come into His
presence you know the emerging Church
teaches that we are to bring God into
our
presence right that's what Elder Howard
was talking about
earlier but the Bible teaches that we
are to go into his presence read Psalm
100 come into His Gates into his court
with singing and with
praise and when we go into the most holy
place of the Heavenly Sanctuary you know
often times we think I see the Ark of
the Covenant and I open up the box
inside of the rocks and there's the pot
of mana and there's Aaron's rod and on
the external part I see the book of the
law and that's all well and good but we
need to be looking at the high priest
folks how often do we miss the high
priest you keep your fix your eyes fixed
on the high priest he's going to do with
you exactly what he needs to do you
don't have to look at the law and try to
figure out well where's my
problem just as the young man came to
Jesus and said good Master what good
thing must I do to inherit eternal
life and Jesus said why callest thou me
good there's none good but God basically
he was saying all right you've been
listening to my teaching for a little
while and you have come to the
conclusion in your own heart that I am
who I say that I am and who people
Proclaim that I am
so now we're going to have a little bit
of
dialogue you can't simply just look at
the law and think that you're
righteous or think that something may be
right or not right you have to listen to
what I have to say now if you would
enter into life keep the
Commandments young man says which one so
Jesus goes through a list and he says
all these things I've kept through my
youth up what do I still
lack and Jesus said you lack
a sense of complete and utter surrender
to the Lord because your heart is
Covetous and
covetousness Begins the progress down
the path of
sin because it's when we are coveting
something we begin to
lie and then we lie and then it leads to
perhaps
infidelity and then perhaps it even
leads to murder
to
theft Disobedience to parents and now we
cross the bridge over into God's realm
and everything now becomes reprehensible
to his character because we say we're
living a certain way but we're taking
his name in
vain we say that we are Christians but
we're living like the devil you see
folks we cannot spend six days in
Babylon and one day in
Israel every day has to be entered into
his Gates that's right we live in the
antitypical day of
atonement which means we live in a
Perpetual Sabbath of Rest In
Christ let us choose to do judgment job
34 says let us know among ourselves what
is
good Psalms 98 says the Lord shall judge
the world in righteousness he shall
Minister judgment to the people in
uprightness whose uprightness the
uprightness of Christ
the meek will he guide in judgment and
the meek will he teach his way and the
meek shall inherit the
earth do you see the connection here is
this a plain reading of the
text okay just want to make
sure hear my voice according unto thy
loving kindness O Lord Quicken me
according to thy
judgment wherewithal shall a young man
cleanse his way the answer is given by
giving heed thereto according to Thy
Word
Thy word have I hid in mine heart that I
might not sin against
thee that's the work of the
Judgment the work of the judgment is so
that we can get into such a hidden
relationship with Christ hiding the word
in us so that we don't have to
sin 1 John 2 verse1 says my little
children these things write I unto you
that you sin
not in other words that you don't
sin he's basically saying we need to
stop
sinning
now we cannot continue to indulge the
lusts of the flesh the lusts of the eyes
and the pride of life and think because
we're going to church on the right day
that we're going to
heaven because the Sabbath teaches
something much greater than going to
church on the correct day remember there
are seventh day Baptists there are
Church of God seventh day and other
Sabbath keeping denominations but they
don't know anything about finishing the
work but yet we go to them and all these
other folks for them to teach us when we
should be teaching
them but the problem is we can't teach
them anymore because we ourselves don't
know what we
believe we've got to get back to the
historical understanding of who we are
as sth the
Adventists I Beech you therefore
Brethren by the mercies of God that you
present your bodies a Living Sacrifice
what happens when a sacrifice is given
what's the end result
death holy acceptable unto God which is
your reasonable service and that word
can also be translated as worship we're
going to come back to that
momentarily and be not conformed to this
world but be you transformed by the
renewing of your mind what mind the mind
of Christ
that you may prove what is that good
acceptable and perfect will of God
Christ Alone is good Christ's sacrifice
alone is acceptable Christ Alone is
perfect but he can give all of that to
us if we would but
surrender and walk as he
walked except a man be born again he
cannot see the kingdom of God we must be
born
again we must have the mind of
Christ we must walk in the spirit
because we are told in Zephaniah 3:13
that the remnant of Israel shall not do
iniquity nor speak lies neither shall a
deceitful tongue be found in their
mouths for they shall feed and lie down
and None Shall make them afraid this is
final generation theology here
folks this is what we are all about as a
movement we have been given great and
exceeding great and precious promises
that by these we might be partakers of
the divine nature why having escaped the
corruption that is in the world through
lust 2 Peter 1:4 all of this why 2 Peter
1:10 that we might not
fall we don't have to
fall my little children as I mentioned
before these things write I unto you
that you sin not but then John goes on
to say With A Little Bit Stronger
language he says whosoever commits sin
transgresses also the law we agree with
that do we not that's the only
definition of sin given in the entire
scripture sin is the transgression of
the law but follow me here for a
moment we're going to unpack this a
little bit the law is an Express
revelation of the character of God would
you agree with me that it is Holy that
it is just that it is pure we would
agree
correct 1 John 4:8 says God is
love and that the fruit of the spirit is
love
charity and it's exhibited through joy
peace longsuffering patience kindness
Temperance and so
forth
so if the law is an expression of God's
character which in and of itself is
inestimable love
then sin is a failure to have the
character of God and love as he
loved which includes not only thinking
the right things or saying the right
things but doing the right
things Jesus went about doing
good and we are to walk in those
steps with the right
motivation I'm not talking about a
social gospel here I'm talking about
righteousness by faith the faith fath of
Jesus not in
Jesus you know that he was manifested to
take away our sin and in him is no sin 1
John 35 writes and now John gets a
little bit
tough whosoever abideth in him sinth not
whosoever sinth hath not seen him
neither known him whosoever is born of
God do not commit sin for his seed that
is Christ remaineth in him and he cannot
sin because he is born of
God now let's draw the conclusion if we
are
sinning it essentially is saying that we
are not connected to the Life
Source we have either intentionally or
perhaps even unwittingly disconnected
the
lifeline because we can't think that we
can move the Lord over into the
passenger seat and drive the the car and
not have an
accident you have to let him drive and
don't be either a backseat or next to
the seat
driver let him drive he will give us
every Victory he will bring us from
strength unto strength and victory unto
Victory the righteousness of Christ will
not cover one cherished
sin Christ object lessons page 316
and when we understand this loving
relationship when we understand what it
means to be hidden in Christ we will
then receive the same exhortation that
Nathaniel meant when he re received when
he first met Christ behold an Israelite
indeed in whom is no
gu what a
wonderful first words to hear out of
Christ's mouth and isra Israelite indeed
in whom is no
G so what does it all mean when it comes
to our role as Sabbath Keepers seventh
day
Adventists Leviticus 19:30 says you
shall keep my sabbaths and reverence My
Sanctuary I am the Lord so there's a
connection here between the Sabbath and
the
sanctuary so the real question is how do
we enter the finishing
work through the Sabbath
we enter into the Sabbath by
faith because the whole concept of
worship him that made points us back to
the creation and the reason it points us
back to the creation is because after
six days God finished his work on the
seventh day and prepared for Adam and
Eve who were
perfect okay created Mankind in His
image and brought them into the
sanctuary and he called that Sanctuary
the
Sabbath but because of a broken
relationship now we have a
disconnect but God needs to use the
Sabbath to bring us back into the
sanctuary and he brings us into the
sanctuary to cleanse
Us in Hebrews 4:9 giving not only a
physical but also a spiritual
application of the Sabbath we read now
I'm going to read from the lamba
translation this is a Aramaic
translation into English it says it is
therefore the duty of the people of God
to keep the Sabbath
is a direct translation from the Aramaic
language now moving back to the King
James verse 10 says for he that is
entered into his rest whose rest God's
rest he has also ceased from his own
works as God did from his pointing us
back to the
creation Now get this let us labor
therefore to enter into that rest lest
we fall by the same example of
unbelief why did they fa what was the
unbelief they would not enter into
Canaan and Canaan was a symbol of rest
it was a symbol of preparing the people
of God for a greater work than wandering
around in the
wilderness and we too are now being
brought up to that same point getting
ready to cross into the Heavenly
Canaan but we first have to come to a
test the test that ancient Israel had
was are we going to go in or are we not
going to go in are we going to believe
the spies report the two and follow and
do what the Lord has said are we going
to believe the 10 you notice it's always
the minority that tends to be
right not the majority and I get a
little bit disconcerted when I think
okay how many people made it under the
boat eight how many people made it out
of Sodom four but then three and how
many of the
original uh of those who came out of
Egypt made it into Canaan two the
numbers are getting smaller and smaller
I get a little bit concerned here but
what's the Lord trying to tell
us that we need to listen to him and not
to
self there are two accounts given of the
Sabbath in the scripture the first one
is in Exodus 20: 8- 11 of which we're
very familiar it points us back to the
creation but the other one is given in
Deuteronomy 5: 12-15 it does not point
us back to the creation but rather it
talks about the deliverance from Egypt
and how the Lord delivered us with a
mighty arm in other words it gives us a
picture of
redemption and because the first giving
in Exodus points us back to Creation it
it shows us that through a the redeeming
strength and arm of Christ we can be
recreated Into His Image in other words
we can be fully restored but the door to
the sanctuary is through the Sabbath we
have to enter into his
rest to God's rest we cannot work work
our way into heaven and we cannot sit
and warm a Pew Sabbath the Sabbath
thinking that we are in the right
relationship we have to understand the
finishing
work it's important to note that only
Jesus can do the work we have no
righteousness of our own that we bring
to the table zero although there are
some teaching that you come to Christ
with a little bit of righteousness and
that as we grow in Grace we get more
righteous but that's contrary to what
the gospel says the gospel says I come
full of
selfishness but if I allow the spirit to
come in if he increases and I decrease
then my selfishness decreases and is and
the only thing that's left is the
righteousness of
Christ the first one is a picture of
evolution we don't get
better we get
dead that's what happens got to
understand
that Galatians 2:20 says what I am
crucified with Christ what's the end
result of of crucifixion usually
death nevertheless I
live yet not I but Christ liveth in me
and the life which I now live in the
flesh I live by the faith of the Son of
God here is the patience of the Saints
here are they that keep the Commandments
of God and the faith of
Jesus not in
Jesus we must have his faith the just
shall live by his
faith we need to understand understand
that the whole purpose is a life
completely consecrated and
surrendered and here's where it gets
real are we ready for the fiery
trial we know that there's a Sunday law
coming but it's much more than a Sunday
law folks it's about a false system of
worship and there are many facets to
that of which I don't have the time to
get into this
morning but I will say this
we have to be in a consecrated
relationship with Jesus
Christ we have to be so completely sold
out and surrendered to him and be
prepared for the test to come otherwise
we're going to bow down to the golden
image we're all familiar with Daniel
chapter
3 haniah mishael and Azariah I'm sorry I
refused to use their Babylonian
names they are standing out on the plane
of dur now do you think that image just
popped up overnight that golden statue
uhuh no it didn't it takes time to build
something of such
stature so people are going by all the
time going gee I wonder what that is now
take a look in the world apply it to
today use the typology here and we're
watching all the actions of the Pope
right and we see what's going
on but what are we doing about it what
does it really mean to us are we getting
caught up in the sensationalism or do we
understand that there's a work that
needs to be done let's continue so now
the day comes and the command goes
forward when you hear the sound of the
Cornet the flute the harp the sac butut
the saltry and all these various kinds
of music that you will bow down to the
golden image and anyone that doesn't bow
down to the image is going to be cast in
the fiery
furnace and so of course the music plays
you know the stuff that takes away your
prefrontal cortex and throws it away and
so now they're all Ben numbed and they
bow down to the golden image but
three Three Men and so of course the
king sees and says bring those guys to
me and then he's it's you I didn't
realize that it was you so I'm going to
give you another chance you see kings in
the ancient world didn't usually give
you a second chance but he had a a a
wonderful liking for haniah mishael and
Azariah and he says all right we're
going to try this again and and the guy
say
listen we don't care what you do we're
not going to bow down Savi your rock
music for
yourself you know you can play it and
take away your own prefrontal cortex but
we are not going to do anything and so
of course the king gets very angry and
what does he do he binds them hand and
foot and throws them into the fire and
they don't
burn now here's my question why don't
they burn
you see brothers and sisters sin is a
combustible
material it burns right okay but when we
go back to Daniel chapter 1 we find that
in verse four that they were without
blemish they were perfect they were
upright they had purposed in their
hearts not to be defiled by anything
that came from the
King they knew there was a work of
prepar op ation that had to be
done that they had to get right with
their maker that they had to have sin
taken out of their lives so they're cast
Into the Fire there's nothing to burn
folks except that which bound
them and what's the second part of the
first Angel's message give glory to him
and they did because they feared God and
the fourth man was revealed in the fire
you see who is our righteousness Christ
is our our
righteousness he will give us the
victory every single
time so long as we surrender to him you
want Victory surrender I know that's a
paradox I get it being an ex-military
guy but that's truth whether we like it
or
not so we need to understand that by
living in this antitypical day of
atonement we must be preparing our souls
for for a work greater than ourselves we
talk about the latter rain we want the
latter rain to
fall get right with God fear him so that
you might give him
glory because the whole point of glory
and the Fulfillment of that glory is
this work that's being done in us and
through us and when God's people hum
humble themselves and allow the Lord to
do the mighty work he's been wanting to
do since this judgment began we will
then see the fall of the latter rain is
that what you want brothers and sisters
amen second selected messages 380 says
None but those who have been Overcoming
By the blood of the lamb and the word of
their testimony will be found with the
loyal in the Troth nun what part of none
do we not understand here without spot
or stain of sin without guile in their
mouths see this is all 144,000 language
here by the way we must be divested of
our self-righteousness and arrayed in
the righteousness of
Christ the ones who refuse to enter into
this deeper work will be sifted out the
precious wheat separated from the
chaff those who are faithful and are
prepared for the trial to come those who
are wise and have oil in their vessels
will proclaim the fourth Angel's message
with a strong
voice Babylon the great is Fallen is
Fallen come out of her my people and be
not partake
of her sins and receive not of her
plagues brothers and sisters we all have
friends who have been deceived by the
sophistries of the enemy at one point or
another and what's creeping into our
church right now
is the worst of all
evils because it disconnects the very
nature of Christ from his people the
fact that the god of Heaven the Eternal
one clothed himself with Humanity to
demonstrate and give an example of how
to redeem his chosen ones to bring them
back into communion and to
Fellowship so we need to tackle this
challenge that we have been given we
need to meet it as the prophet says but
we have to be very careful I'm going to
share with you a quote from thoughts
from the Mount of blessing because it's
so important to understand this as we
move forward from this point forward not
until you feel that you could sacrifice
your own self-dignity and even lay down
your life in order to save an airing
brother have you cast The Beam out of
your own eye so that you are prepared to
help your
brother see often times we see this moat
but don't realize that we have a beam in
our own eye then you can approach him
and touch his heart no one has ever been
reclaimed from a wrong position by
censure and reproach but many have thus
been driven from Christ and led to seal
their hearts against conviction a tender
Spirit a gentle winning deportment May
save the heiring and hide a multitude of
sins the revelation of Christ in your
own character will have a transforming
power upon all with whom you come in
contact let Christ be daily made
manifest in you and he will reveal
through you the Creative Energy of his
word a gentle persuasive yet Mighty
influence to recreate other Souls into
the beauty of our Lord and our God
brothers and sisters are you ready to
enter into this
work that is why we are here that is why
we have been chosen that is the power of
the Everlasting gospel there is no
middle ground here we either choose the
side of the Lord or we choose the side
of the enemy how long halt ye between
two
opinions if the Lord be God serve
him but if baale be God then serve him
either way make up your
mind make up your
mind are we ready to experience a deeper
level of Christianity than we've ever
had before it's here for the taking and
the Prophet tells us through the words
of Jesus himself let him that is a
thirst
come and whosoever will let him take of
the Water of Life
freely freely for it's all there
brothers and sisters let us go forward
now to do the work which we have been
called to do amen amen let us pray
Father in
heaven we thank you again that we have
had the privilege to meet here on this
your
Sabbath father you have given us this
day to understand a revelation of who
you are so that we might understand the
cleansing sanctifying work that you
would have done through us through Jesus
Christ we ask Lord that you would give
us your strength your patience your Zeal
so that we might be faithful to the end
for it is in Jesus name we pray amen e